زعيم روسيا فلاديمير بوتين وهو جالس
يستعرض قدرات بلده النوويه يدرك حد اليقين
ان اي حرب تستعمل فيها هذه الاسلحه ستكون
مدمره قد تهدد وجوده شخصيا على سطح الكوكب
مخبا سري لدى زعيم يوجد تحت مجمع فاخر يقع
فوق منطقه منحدره تطل على البحر الاسود
المكان مخصص لمواجهه احتمال حدوث حرب
نوويه حسب موقع بيزنس
تبلغ مساحته 190 الف قدم مربع وتكلفته
مليار دولار يقع على منحدر وعر يتمتع بكل
رفاهيه يمكن ان يرغب فيها بوتين المخبا
السري لبوتين اسفل مجمعه يتكون من نفقين
منفصلين يمكن الوصول اليهما عبر مصعد
كهربائي يهبط اكثر من 50 مترا تحت السطح
النفقان مغلقان بالاسمنت السميك ومزودان
بما يكفي من الماء العذب والتهويه اللازمه
ومقصورات واسعه لخدمه الشخصيات المهمه
لايام بل لاسابيع النفق السفلي يؤدي الى
ممر متحرك يقود الى الخارج يضم كافه انواع
الامن والسلامه النفقان مجهزان بانظمه
للحريق والمياه ومياه المجاري كلها ترمي
لكي يكون الشخص على قيد الحياه او يتمكن
من الهرب
الاستعداد للحرب النوويه بمخابئ محصنه لا
يخص بوتين فحسب بل لدى الزعماء في كل
الدول النوويه خطه الطوارئ القصوى في حال
اندلاع حرب مدمره بمن فيهما الرئيس
الامريكي الذي توجد مخابئه النوويه تحت
البيت الابيض وفي ولايه فيرجينيا بلال
البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات